. Some things seems to really have Republican's
in a highly triggerable state lately, last
week, or maybe it was the week before, they
stormed into an impeachment related meeting
claiming that they wanted access to impeachment
stuff that was happening secretly in the basement
of some building with only Democrats.
Of course, we later found out that many of
the same Republicans that stormed in demanding
access have access to impeachment documents
and to witnesses.
Since many of those Republicans are on the
committees that are involved in the impeachment
inquiry yesterday, instead of storming in,
they stormed out.
It doesn't matter though.
They just want to be storming around this
time, storming out of a veteran's affairs
committee meeting, refusing to vote on a healthcare
bill for women veterans.
What is wrong with this people, with these
people?
This is how it went.
The house veteran's affairs committee was
meeting about a bill for women veterans healthcare
to get them healthcare Republicans did what
they often do, and sometimes Democrats do
this too.
They suggest a variety of amendments which
Democrats rightly identified as poison pill
amendments, California, Democrat, Mark the
Canno stop the debate on these proposed amendments
because as he says, these are toxic partisan
amendments.
They wouldn't actually improve healthcare
for women veterans, which was the point of
the discussion that we're having about this
bill.
The Republicans became irate, how dare you
accuse us of that and then a whole bunch of
them stormed out and it was film.
Take a look.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
now it's true.
The amendments they were proposing had no
place in this discussion whatsoever to bill
about women veterans healthcare.
They were proposing amendments related to
veterans, firearms rights for childcare.
These are fine things to discuss and debate
and to legislate, but this is a bill about
women veterans healthcare and this is a really
common thing in American politics.
Amendments that are unrelated are introduced.
Sometimes the point is to get things passed
as amendments that you couldn't possibly get
past the standalone bills.
That's one reason for these crazy amendments.
The other reason, sometimes crazy amendments
are proposed is to prevent the bill in total
from passing by suggesting crazy and unrelated
things.
The good news here is that the bill called
the Deborah Sampson act was passed by the
committee.
Even without Republicans voting on it, they
had the votes and now it will go to a full
vote in the house.
I don't really believe in stuff like karma,
but if there are just desserts in our world,
Republicans would deserve to be kicked out
of office in 2020 by the people that they
have so endlessly screwed over.
I'm talking about veterans, I'm talking about
farmers.
I'm, I mean in a sense, I'm talking about
most, uh, groups in general, no matter how
you slice or dice it.
Now that I think about it, but this is another
example of Republican's love the military
when it's useful and politically advantageous.
If it's about supporting some hair-brained
intervention in some part of the world, let's
support the troops and not say that the mission
they're on is not a good one.
And then when it's not so useful when it comes
to providing them health care, when it comes
to a former members of the military who might
have something to say that's negative about
Donald Trump, like Lieutenant Colonel Alexander
Veneman, all of a sudden, all of that pro
military stuff evaporates very, very quickly.
This has come up so many times recently on
the show because recently it's been particularly
prevalent and extraordinarily brazen.
They don't really care about the troops in
the real way that they should.
Making sure that they are properly cared for
when they come back from, uh, engagements
abroad.
All of the other things that we've been talking
about, this is yet another one of those instances.
Vote on the bill.
Get the women veterans health care.
No, we need amendments about gun ownership.
Give me a break.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David taco Huntsville,
and follow me on instagram@daviddottactthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com.